[Music]
[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studio this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your
life and your money my name is anthony
o'neil host of the youtube and podcast
show the table
with the one and only me anthony o'neal
and i'm excited to be uh hosting the
ramsey show
today solo uh dave is out
our personalities are out impacting the
world
and um they asked me to hold the fort
down
and i said i could do that i could do
that because i got an amazing squad
you know i got kelly on the phones she's
gonna make sure i'm all right
you know james child is in the building
helping us out and
uh you america your phone calls are
gonna be amazing and i'm just looking at
the beautiful people
out here in a beautiful weather it's 80
degrees out here
y'all are smart to come today because
yesterday was 90. 90 something degrees
and y'all are so smart and i love this
young couple out here he he held her
real
tight he's like that's my queen right
there i like this man so listen
uh we're gonna have a good day today
y'all know me when i get on the ramsay
show with dave with the personality
without the personalities
um i keep it real i keep it real
relevant and
relatable they call me the millennial
guy i love talking about money
i love talking about relationships so if
you single and you got questions about
what you
what should you be doing with your money
while you're single how much did you
spend on your first date
uh should you go ahead and just x her
out of your budget give me a call
we can talk about it all today triple
eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and it's going to be
an amazing amazing day as a matter of
fact
we're going to start off in sacramento
uh california with michael a good
afternoon how can i help man
hey there anthony um very good to talk
to you
all times fam appreciate everything
you're doing um
i actually just wanted to repair in
regards to um
me and my wife we are uh i'm a
father of one uh with another one on the
way um
our life is progressing uh we are pretty
rooted here in sacramento we
i have um my parents that are retired my
wife's parents that are retired they
both help with this
with the kids so it's awesome um but we
are
at the point where we're deaf free we
have probably about 51 000 in the bank
right now um
with the housing market the way it is
not really looking to buy a home
immediately right now but within
the next two years we just wanted to see
um
what your thoughts are in regards to a
30-year mortgage versus a 15-year
mortgage
being on a you know price range is
usually pretty higher than most of the
country
yeah yeah yeah i definitely understand
um it's such a great question
um so you got about 51 000 in your
savings now is this 51
000 on top of your emergency fund
michael
uh no not on top of that so it's just 51
000 code i'd say
three bucks worth of savings for us
would be
about fifteen thousand dollars okay see
about 15 so
you have about yeah just kind of getting
started okay cool great so
how much what's your household income
uh my household income is about a
hundred
and twelve thousand right now 112 so
that's you and your wife combined
yes correct okay cool how much of a
house are you looking to buy
uh anywhere close to um
i would say it just would need to be at
least three bedroom two bathroom
preferably in a better neighborhood to
raise markets
yeah so that's pretty much right now so
that you're looking at what about two
thousand square feet in between
seventeen hundred and twenty two hundred
square feet
correct in sacramento so you're looking
at about about a half a mill to maybe
about 650.
yeah probably about a half a mil parking
budget yeah yeah probably about half a
million yeah
um and so you will need 20 down okay
uh this is what this is what i teach
this is what we all teach here at ramsay
solutions
uh the goal is to have 20 down uh
michael now bare minimum
10 okay the 20 is so that you can avoid
a pmi your private mortgage insurance so
when you choose a 30 years
and this is something i love to spend a
little bit of time let it just marinate
for people
okay you're gonna be in debt for 30
years uh
number one number two you're more than
likely if you get into a 30-year
loan you're going to be paying the pmi
so you're going to be paying your
mortgage payment
and an interest but you're going to be
paying something else called a pmi
that is not helping neither side okay
and so we want you to get a 15 year so
that way you can get out of debt quicker
you're going to get into a 15 with
equity because you put down 20
and those are the two main things that
you do now listen and be honest with you
are we going to you know scream at you
and go crazy because you get a 30-year
loan no but the wise decision
is to get a fixed rate over 15 years
with the gold 20 sit down with the bare
minimum of
10 down okay so this way you can get
yourself and your family out of debt uh
quicker now you're already out of debt
michael so i don't want to see you go
get get out of debt and then you have a
fully funded emergency fund you're
investing into your retirement
how old are you oh yeah man come on
brother
you're with me maybe you're a millennial
we got to do this thing right come on
now so this is what i want you to do
i want you to stack up to 20 because
you're not in a rush
and i think the market is going to be
like this for the next 12 to 18 months
and so what i want to do is i want to
see you sit here
work hard save as much money as you
possibly can
get that 20 get into a 15 year
make sure your mortgage payment is 25
um or lower than your net pay and then
choose a home that you know you're going
to be in for the next few years
and i guarantee you when you get inside
this house you're going to see how close
you are to paying it off you're going to
pay this thing off
you're going to be you know in the mid
40s uh
100 debt free with a beautiful home with
a beautiful mortgage
and um you're going to get real we're
really excited and so i love it
how many more kids do you all want down
the road
um maybe one more but we'll see
hopefully so that means that you may
need a four bedroom keep that in mind
because you know
if if you're a family man you two kids
and maybe a bonus room so i've
even think about that maybe you hold off
for two more years on saving up
so you can get you know a good four
bedroom with a good backyard and make
this your home for the next few years as
you're raising your kids
think about it you have a debt-free
couple debt-free family paid for a
fully funded college fund fully funded
fifteen percent investment in baby step
four and your kids are 18 years old
going to college debt free parents are
debt free
that is such a beautiful legacy to start
and i really want america to hear me on
this
i think we all should be really dreaming
about
the future what do you want your legacy
to look like what do you want
uh your generation uh that you raise
that you bring them to this earth to
look like
i remember i was watching um a a
a show with oprah and steve harvey and
steve harvey was telling
the story of his grandmama and she said
do you
know your great-grandfather's last name
he said no i don't she said do you know
why
he said i really don't she said because
he didn't leave you with anything
what are you leaving your people with
are you leaving him with
dead leaving him with pain or you
leaving with joy
peace wealth land knowledge wisdom
that's what i want and we do that by
taking these baby steps
and making sure that we're making the
right decisions why because the caliber
of our future
will be determined by the choices we
made today so let's make the right one
in america you've made the right one
because you're listening to your boy
anthony o'neil
right here on the ramsay show and i'll
be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
the name is anthony o'neil right here on
the ramsey show eight eight two five
five two two five it's a free call but
if you call in just know
keep it real relevant and relatable and
we're going to go out to denver colorado
with miguel we're going to keep it real
with him
hey good afternoon how can we help how
you doing anthony i'm doing all right
man how are you
doing well thank you um so just kind of
a little bit of a dilemma right now so i
am currently 25 years old
okay um i am making about 60 000 a year
right now
hold on we got a dilemma you 25 making
60k
let me hear this dilemma all right let's
see um
so i'm 28 000 in student loans um
the other thing is so i just recently
got engaged um and this is where this
all comes in
i own a 2020 tacoma which i got for 47
and right now i owe
33. obviously my fiance and i we want to
build our own life we want to get our
own place and this and that
um my dilemma right now is in if i
should sell the tacoma
and use that 700 a month i'm paying to
pay out my student loans
save up for a bigger down payment right
now i am saving about a thousand a month
uh but yeah that's kind of where i'm at
right now how much money do you have in
your savings account right now
about 13 thousand
thirteen thousand dollars okay if you
sell this this
car oh it's actually suv right um
it's a truck truck okay yeah um
what can you sell it for so you owe 33
on it what can you get for it
um so the valley on killer blue book for
the base model
it is 41 000 i do have the premiere
package on it
um so i've been looking at i've been
here and i can sell it for up to 43 45
000.
so you can get forty three thousand
dollars right now for the coffee yeah
yeah how much do you love your wife i
mean your future wife
uh love it to death that's why i'm
thinking of selling my babies
with her that's what i'm talking about
brother i'm selling that thing today i'm
getting off the phone
and i'm selling it and what i would do
is i'll go ahead and sell it for
private and see if i can get 45
that'll put you 12k and then what i
would do is honestly
i would take 10k of that go buy a car
add the other 2k uh with the 13
000 you have saved up okay and then i
will use that 15 000
to cash flow your wedding
and and and again i'm not dave and this
is anthony's opinion
i think right now because how much debt
does she have
uh she has about i think it's just her
car which she was about 10 000 on okay
cool
so and what you make 60k
how much does she make so she just
graduated
um so she's still working at her
internship she's only making about 14 an
hour right now
okay so she's about now once she um gets
into her career field
what can she make on average let's say
low low end
well i want to say 20 an hour 20 an hour
okay cool so that
expressed pretty decent all right cool
so this is what i want to suggest to you
man
okay of all seriousness um
one of the things that that i tell
people your car value should never be
more than half of
your salary you're already there so i'm
with you
i'm selling this car uh today and you
know what
if you want to get out of it quickly so
that way you're not
um putting more miles on it i will go
ahead and sell it for
you know 43 000 uh so that way
it gives someone else the benefit and a
little bit of encouragement to get into
it because they're saving two thousand
dollars on the car
so you'll get ten thousand dollars and
you can go ahead and
go buy you a cash car um you could buy a
good cash card in between five and ten
thousand dollars that's reliable to get
you back and forth to work and even
a decent car i mean that's a good honda
it's a good toyota that's a good nissan
altima i mean you can get you can get a
good quality car now it may not be a
truck
uh but it's a good reliable car then the
thirteen thousand dollars i want you to
sit down with your fiance
and i really want y'all to have a
conversation okay and this is something
that
i'm not a relationship expert right but
i am single
and i look forward to having this
conversation with my fiance whenever
um god allows me and blesses me to find
the love of my life i want to ask like
what what what are our goals
like where do we see ourselves in the
next 10 15 years
as a couple okay what do we want do we
want to be homeowners
uh do we want to be traveling around the
world do we want kids
and then we can when we can really
identify that vision then let's work
backwards
and then that should be able to answer
this one question how much money do we
really want to
put into a wedding do we really want to
drop fifteen thousand dollars twenty
thousand dollars on a wedding right now
you know would we rather just put maybe
five grand into a good wedding
and then take this other money and put
it towards our debt so we can move
towards
our goals now i'm not knocking people
who want to spend a lot of money on
their wedding i do not but i do want to
make sure that i give you the
information
miguel and just help set you up to make
the right decision
moving forward makes sense yes yeah so
i would definitely save your car i would
um definitely uh going ahead and have
the conversation with your wife and
start seeing okay what's our
budget for the wedding okay and then
from there you two move forward
but i'm super excited do y'all have a
date for y'all going get married
so yeah so i mean that's kind of where
we're at um plan was to do it september
of uh
next year um in the back of our head we
were also like okay well we could spend
on the wedding we could also spend
on a down payment for a home and later
on if we're
well off financially then we can have
the wedding that we've always wanted
um why are you waiting so long what was
that
why are you waiting so long that's a
that's another year
that's a long engagement brother wedding
wings are so expensive that we just
wanted to save up and not going dead
with the wedding as well you know
wedding doesn't have to be expensive you
you are correct
you make it expensive so i gotta
convince her to do
the same way man you know as a matter of
fact i bet you this
i taught you this much okay hang up the
phone call your girlfriend
okay tell her to call back into the show
tell her to tell kelly that anthony told
me to call the ramsey show because he
want to talk to me
about wedding and how much we should pay
for it because here's the thing america
you know we do not have to spend a lot
of money
on getting married no we don't have to
do it
who cares if america says we should
spend 20 grand 15 grand
america ain't paying for the bill okay
so here's the thing you set the budget
and you
get creative with that budget that's the
bottom line
so tell your fiance to give me a call
triple eight eight two five five
two two five tell her hey just tell the
teller kelly that anthony told me to
call
and she know she already know but in all
jokes aside
miguel wants to stay on the line uh
kelly's gonna pick up
and because you're getting married i
really want to help set this young
couple up
25 years old good head on your shoulder
um
i'm gonna give you a free year to ramsey
plus um
i want you and your fiance to walk
through that
together okay together not solo
but together and seriously if your
fiance wants to call in and talk to
me about wedding advice i i would love
to give her some suggestions on how she
can get creative for the budget
you know but it's it's so funny you guys
that
every time i'm on the show with dave or
even on my show the table with anthony
o'neil
it's so funny how this younger
generation we just feel as if we got to
spend
a whole bunch of money on a wedding and
you don't have to
okay now if you want to and you have the
means to do it
you have the financial resources to do
it cool
great but if you're if you're in debt if
if if you barely have a job no
man my sister she didn't spend 10k you
know when she got married y'all she
didn't spend ten thousand dollars
and she had a beautiful wedding in the
backyard
of a beautiful big old big old house it
was like a mansion
it was almost like fifteen thousand
square feet and we just rented the
backyard
dropped a few thousand dollars over
there and the most expensive part is the
food
now kelly this is why i think i'm gonna
be single for a long time because i
ain't spending a lot of money for the
food you know
i have this problem kelly and america
probably ain't gonna like me when i say
this but it is what it is okay
why do i gotta pay for y'all to come
celebrate me getting married
why i got to feed you to come celebrate
me getting married
see you so i'm saying kelly talking i
don't want to look at it cause she a
woman
i'ma look over here cause we got a debt
free scream coming up next on the next
segment
but i don't understand that i gotta
spend fifteen
thousand dollars so you can eat at my
wedding
i'm not if i can't afford it i can't
afford it that's what i'm gonna say
that's exactly what i'm i'ma say but i'm
excited though because coming up next on
the next segment you guys
we're going to the debt free stream
stage we got a young couple out there
i'm excited i'm pumped so uh tell your
friends tell your family
i tell everyone to tune in to the ramsay
show anthony's on here
coming up next we want to hear how some
amazing young people
paid off all day this is the ranch
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and 6 gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
the name is anthony o'neill right here
on the ramsey show and i am excited
because we have a dope
young couple i said dope we have a
amazing young couple on the debt free
screen stage
uh nathan and kelly how y'all doing this
afternoon
hey anthony good oh man now i did say
young y'all are young right
yeah i'm 28. 29. yeah oh what that's
gonna be so good
okay okay okay so nathan and kelly uh
let's start off here
uh where do you all live milwaukee
wisconsin milwaukee wisconsin okay cool
and how much have you paid off
133 410
410 okay cool how long did it take you
three and a half years three and a half
years how much money were y'all making
during that time uh we started at around
58 000
and now we're at about 98. wait wait
wait what do y'all do
i'm a graphic designer okay yep uh
marketing coordinator
graphic designer marketing coordinator
and you paid off about hundred and
thirty-four thousand dollars
yep okay wait a minute okay all right
let's talk about this what kind of debt
is this
uh mostly student loans but um in the
beginning there was some credit cards
car loans all the normal stuff out of
the 134 how many of that was
how much was that with student loans
close to a hundred yeah yeah
a hundred thousand dollars in student
loans and then the other stuff was just
regular stuff credit cards right
yeah uh what else was it any cars yeah
two cars two cars
two cars okay did y'all sell the cars or
did y'all just pay them off
uh we paid them off you paid them off
okay y'all y'all are all right with me
so
talk to me about the journey what
happened that got you all on the journey
so in the beginning i think i just had
heard of it um
i started watching the youtube videos
for a while while we were both in school
okay and then um he graduated
before me and then i did and i finally
got the book
um he was like a little bit resistant
but he's like well i can read a book you
know so
he read it and then um we both got
excited about it
so so why were you hesitant to read the
book in the beginning like honestly
dave is not here so you can really tell
me i'm i'm just a spender like naturally
beforehand like i was just like i didn't
see
like the point like i was young and i
was like it'll all get figured out like
i don't have to worry about it right now
okay and we had a big amount um yeah it
seemed impossible
yeah 134 thousand dollars i mean
i mean y'all did that in three and a
half years
but yeah y'all were grinding right now
i mean what how did you do it i mean
what happened how
yeah walk us through this how did you
pay off what was the number one thing
that helped you pay off 134 000
yeah well we had a big why um
we wanted to start a family and
at that point in time we had no idea how
we would do that and actually
have the life we wanted you know um
you've talked about that before you know
that's like your biggest why
and you know our first couple years of
marriage they weren't
great you know we were really broke
we couldn't do anything that we wanted
to do
you know we wanted to take our kids on
vacation
and about halfway through the this
journey
we became foster parents so that's what
we're doing now
oh man that has to be a beautiful thing
and you're right one of the biggest
things that i teach um is
is if your why doesn't make you cry then
the price of commitment will make you
cry
yeah and it sounded like your your
family your kids
were uh your biggest biggest why
and and i love i i honestly love that um
what did it take what was like the key
thing to you getting out of debt what
was it was it a budget was it
uh what was it um i think like the
budget was
key and just like good communication
between each other yeah um
just because like in the beginning it
was rough you know like we didn't always
agree on everything but by the end it
was like we were in sync we were having
monthly budget meetings making sure
everything you know that every dollar
budget using the app
yeah that was really helpful now what
was the hardest thing now i'm curious as
a young couple
going on this journey you know you're in
your 20s
you know and i'm pretty sure your
friends are looking at you like what are
y'all doing what are you talking about
like
what was some of the what was one of the
hardest things that you two
had to get through yeah i think that was
the hardest thing you know we kept it
pretty quiet
you know in the beginning for the first
couple years um
i think people just thought we were like
homebodies and like just didn't care
about stuff but
that's not really what it was you know
we really just put our blinders on and i
think that's the
biggest key because even if we looked at
the whole amount of debt we had to pay
off
we had no idea like how we'd ever get to
that point we just had to worry about
today
and like the the debt we were paying off
like the credit cards in the beginning
and um it got hard even after we had
done the cars and stuff and we had to do
those big student loan payments we were
like oh gosh
uh yeah so putting our blinders on and
ignoring it i remember like i
didn't want to get a 20 haircut once
since i'm like really
like 20 isn't gonna fix anything but it
was the principle of it you know
i love it to the young people listening
right now really to everyone but you
know i love when i have
young people on the stage um i love to
hear what
what's your encouragement to other young
millennials that are coming up saying
hey
i don't have to pay off the debt i'm
young i'm just going to enjoy this i'm
just going to write it
what would you say to that young person
that's listening to you all today on why
it's important to avoid debt
or if you have debt paid off yeah
um if you do nothing nothing's gonna
change in your life
um and that was we did felt almost like
we didn't have a choice but to do it
because
we didn't want to keep living like that
forever we actually got it done
faster than we expected to yeah because
we just focus so intensely on it
yeah yeah yeah what about you man um
yeah i think you know really just
keeping your mind on your why too is
really important like
when we started our family and stuff i
just knew like um
i wanted to be able to give my kids like
things i didn't have um
i love it they're over here getting
emotional y'all
they better make me cry so what's next
you guys are debt free
uh what's next for this family learning
how to have fun
with that money again you know it's an
adjustment you know
i mean like money doesn't make you happy
yeah but
it buys you some fun so we're trying to
figure out
what things we care about that we're
willing to spend money on now listen
here
i'm gonna tell you all right now money
doesn't buy you happiness but it's sure
enough can play a huge role in you being
happy
especially when you don't have any debt
i'm really excited about that
so who were your biggest cheerleaders
along this journey
i don't know people kind of cheered us
on but i don't
think they understood it they just were
like oh good
good job good keep doing you but you
didn't really get it i love it
i love it i love it i love it well you
guys uh man
this is absolutely amazing we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you
and the total money makeover so that way
you all can give that to someone else
since you all have already read the book
and she forced you to read it so i want
you to give it
to someone uh alone you liked it yeah
alone in your journey so
all right nathan and kelly from
milwaukee they paid off 134 thousand
dollars
in three and a half years making fifty
eight thousand dollars and ninety eight
thousand
dollars count it down let me hear a debt
free screen
all right three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
well you see um
i love this you know i i love coming on
dave ramsey show and seeing
a bunch of young people out here taking
this is a 28 year old 29 year old
who are now 100 debt free american i
want you to listen to their heart
uh they are foster parents they are
sowing seeds
into other young people and i love that
because now they can do that from a
debt-free perspective they can be
generous
not just with their time and their home
but now they can actually
enjoy their money enjoy the resources
god has trusted them with
to honestly be a blessing to someone
else i don't care what no one's saying
these young people paid off 134 thousand
dollars
started off making 58 000 a year and
ended at 98 000
as a household income and paid off in
three and a half years
that is absolutely amazing
i don't care what you say if you say you
can't do it you're lazy
if you say you can't do it you're whack
yeah i said it
okay if you say you cannot get out of
debt it just means you simply don't want
to get out of debt
then if you believe you can't do it i
challenge you to give me a call
if you can prove to me that you can't
get out of debt i'll bow down
but everyone all things are possible
i'm about to go out here and celebrate
with these young people this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
i just had to let that ride out ramsay
uh
bob's in there killing it i like this
guy i like this music right here on the
ramsay show
huh i ain't saying that oh i said bob
why did i say bob ben
i'm so sorry oh lord hey y'all welcome
back to the ramsey show
uh ben is sitting in for our producer
james child and i said bob i don't know
why i said bob i'm so sorry ben you're
amazing
that's all right man yo you're killing
the music man actually you're better
than james on the music i'm gonna be
real don't tell them though
um uh yo triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to give
us a call
uh my name is anthony o'neill filling in
for the other ramsey personalities and
the lead personality dave ramsey
and all of them are out impacting the
world and so they asked me to do the
show
and i said sure thing uh so don't forget
you guys to find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer
of custom window covering you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions to imply
so today's question america comes from
sophie in alabama
she says i'm a college student and about
to get married well congratulations
my fiance and i have good savings but
neither of us have a credit card
good they just have debit i love it
do we need to have credit cards to
establish credit or is it enough
to just be debt free i took a family
finance class and was told i need
a credit card but my mom said that she
heard from this show
the ramsay show that it's not necessary
whoever told you
that you need a credit card wrong okay
you don't
need a credit card what you need is
financial peace what you need is
financial freedom
what you need is a savings account what
you need to be doing
is investing into your future you don't
need debt you don't need a
score uh you don't need a credit card so
you could become an adult no what you
need to do is to live below your means
and pay for cash for everything so that
we can have financial peace
so you can have financial freedom okay
that's what you need you don't need
credit score it bothers me when i hear
people say um
you know that um it's it's something
that i need you know
and here's the truth you know here's the
truth america here's here's the truth
here's the truth
i was told the same thing and i went out
there and got a credit card
because they told me well you need a
credit card for emergencies so i did
just that
and you know what became an emergency
taking her out to dinner
that became an emergency you know what
else became an emergency
buying her roses from 1 800 flowers.com
you know what else became
an emergency is buying her a purse
that became an emergency
i didn't need that no
no a credit score doesn't mean that you
are successful
i know so many people who have a 800
credit score but don't even have 800
in their savings account let me say that
again i know so many people who have a
750 credit score
and don't even have 300 400 in their
bank account
do y'all know i'm gonna teach a second
i'm sorry i gotta calm down this is the
rams show but do you all know
that nearly forty percent of people in
america today don't even have four
hundred dollars in their savings account
nearly 52 percent of the people in
america do not even have a thousand
dollars in their savings account
but we want to talk about having a
credit score
no what you need to do is put money in
your savings account what you need to do
is get out of debt what you need to do
is live below your means
that's what you need to do and i wish
somebody i was
somebody taught me that information
let me tell you what else you need to do
okay
you need to dream a little bit you need
to dream about starting a business
especially ladies
i believe when you start a business you
have ownership okay
and have you been dreaming about
starting a business or maybe you have a
business and you want to take it to the
next
level well no matter what stage you're
at
it's time to make money doing what you
love and the business boutique
conference will help you make it happen
on october 14th through
16th rockstar speakers including the one
and only dave ramsey christy wright
jasmine starr my big sister nona jones
and including myself
that's right we'll cover topics
including social media branding goal
setting in accounting and more
because here's the truth running a
business can be overwhelming
but it doesn't have to be get the
inspiration and the practical steps you
need to chase your version of success
so i want you all to join us for this
three-day event
in person in nashville or chrissy has
set this up
so you can you can attend this event via
live stream
now early bird passes for business
boutique conference are on sale right
now so just text
boutique boutique to 33789
to learn a lot more
this right here will help you accomplish
the things that you need to be doing
which
is financial peace financial freedom
if you can start a business the number
one rising entrepreneur
are ladies ladies get to this conference
if you can get a business started a side
business started
without racking up any debt this can
produce income to help you pay off your
debt to help you go after your dreams
and this is something that i want you to
do so text boutique to three three
seven eight nine uh connor's with us in
sioux falls good afternoon connor how
can we help
hey thanks for taking my call hey thank
you for calling in man you just made my
day
how can i help you man all right so i'm
gonna i'm gonna be like a junior in high
school this
coming fall and i have like fifteen
thousand dollars and i really don't know
what to do with it
don't just slide through that connor you
got fifteen thousand dollars cash
yeah i've been working since i was ten i
said most of it can have like 20 by the
end of the summer
what were you doing uh worked at trap
grounds until i was 14 and worked fast
food the last
two years and got promoted recently and
yeah and you just saving the money
pretty much yeah do you have a car
yep what kind of car you got uh
07 impala did you pay for did your
parents pay for
my parents paid for it i love it you
going to college
yeah i'm thinking of engineering just
day school engineering how's your grades
uh fourth i know 4.0
i like this yo man 4.0 student 15 000
cash in his bank account and he's
already working this is a millionaire by
the time he turns 35 guaranteed
so here's what i want you to do connor
with the money man what i want you to do
is keep that money in your savings
account all right
when you get a full ride to your school
school of choice all right
i want you to go through the first year
without touching that money in the
savings account i want to make sure you
can get through college 100
debt free okay if you can get through
the first two years and you are
guaranteed you don't need
any money to get through the last two
years as far as in
you got transportation you have food you
have everything covered that you would
need
gas all that type of stuff then i would
start investing into
a growth stock mutual fund which is a
roth ira all right
i would start doing that but i do not
want you to start investing this money
until you know for sure 100
that you can graduate from college 100
debt free
if you think there's going to be a
little cause i want you to keep that
money in your savings
so for the first two years of college
don't touch it leave it there
make sure your grants your scholarships
um and everything is covering everything
if it doesn't then yes i want you to use
that money
to make sure that you graduate college
100 debt free
because your greatest investment right
now is in yourself okay
when you can sit here and graduate
college 100
debt free you're going to be 21 22 years
old i think you're gonna graduate
college in three years where you're
going
um so you'll be 21 22 years old debt
free a little bit of money in your
savings account
you start investing around that time uh
15 percent
right man you you're going to be
successful you're going to be successful
i
i wish i was thinking like you at 15
when i was 15 years old i was running my
mouth
chasing the ladies playing sports
and um trying to hide from my parents
you know i was not thinking the way you
were thinking so man thank you so much
for calling in
thank you so much for uh representing uh
the young people correctly
and i'm telling you right now man your
future is going to be
so so bright well that's a wrap for this
hour you guys i want to thank
ben and kelly daniel for taking care of
me this hour
and it's going to be a good one this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the table uh
with anthony o'neil yes the uh youtube
show and podcast show
and i am hosting the ramsay show by
myself today america so you get me
uh our personalities and the lead
personality dave ramsey is
out impacting and uh helping people um
get out of debt
build wealth and so they asked me to
fill in i said absolutely why not
um as long as kelly and ben are here
james missing i don't know where james
is and but it's all good ben
is a better uh music producer than james
don't tell him though and we'll be all
right
but hey the number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five um whenever i'm on the
show you guys i like to keep it real
relevant
and relatable i love having a
conversation
um about all things really you know i am
the only single personality and so i
love actually encouraging and talking to
single people so if you're a single
person and
you're having questions around how to
date around money how to
um you know make good relationship
decisions around money or you're just a
single person how do i start attacking
my debt or getting out of debt and
building wealth as a young single person
yo give us a call if you're anybody um
you want to talk about you know whatever
life money relationships give me a call
you know it's going to be a
fun hour here and i would love to talk
to you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's a number
and zayn is going to kick off this hour
in phoenix arizona
and uh thanks for calling in zane how
can we help
hey yo my man thank you so much for uh
taking my call today it's an absolute
honor to be talking to you
oh man it's an honor to talk to you man
thank you so much for calling in how can
i help you today bro yeah thank you so a
little bit of background about me
um i just graduated uh from arizona
state i'm
23. i'm single graduated with a degree
in supply chain management
um i have currently about twenty two
thousand dollars worth of debt
um after graduating i got a job working
in consulting um so currently making
sixty seven thousand dollars a year okay
um so
during school uh really you know
important for me
my parents made the sacrifice you know
they let me live at home
um and so i made i had a good job
i worked as a server and made a lot of
money
and so made a really stupid purchase um
i purchased some jewelry
um that's that was um you know it
purchased it for about four thousand
dollars and now it's worth about ten
thousand dollars
and um currently trying to just clean up
this debt
and so wondering if i'm getting close to
um you know clearing that debt up like i
said i have that eighteen thousand
dollars to throw out the pile
um and so wondering if i should maybe
sell this jewelry to
close that gap or if you know
maybe hanging onto the jewelry isn't
such a bad idea after all did you just
say you had 18
000 uh to throw at the palace that's all
of your jury added up is about 18 000
oh no no so um i have eighteen thousand
dollars cash that's
not including the jewelry um the debt is
twenty two thousand dollars
uh it's not including my uh emergency
fund or anything
um but i was wondering if i should sell
the jewelry to kind of close the gap
between the 22 and the eighteen
um you know to kind of make that up or
if to
you know maybe just kind of keep going
along the path i was already on
cool so let me make sure how this is
correct you got 22 000 in debt you have
18 000
sitting in your savings then you have
jury that's worth 10
dollars which means technically you have
about twenty eight thousand dollars
uh to your um advantage with a twenty
two thousand dollars in deficit with
debt correct
correct i'm selling the jury gotcha
instantly i'm gonna sell the jury um
because that's just something that you
know we did a millionaire study um last
year right we studied over 10
000 millionaires the number one
millionaire study in america
nobody treats what we just did and when
we talk to these people one of the top
things that they said they do not invest
into
is jury they don't invest into gold they
don't invest into things
only time they invest in the jury's
because they want to get a wedding ring
and get some jury to actually wear on
their their their fingers and stuff like
that so um
i will go ahead and sell the jury this
is going to put you at 28 thousand
dollars
boom i'm gonna pay off the debt of 22
000 i will actually go ahead and take
that 18k
take 17 of that go ahead and put that
towards that
once you sell the jury pay off the rest
of your debt
and then go ahead and get you three
months are you still living with your
parents right now
uh i am but currently i'm about to move
out in about a month
okay um
sixty seven thousand dollars a month i
mean a year
uh you live in arizona so rent's gonna
be
rent's gonna be good okay yep uh do you
have a car note oh i do yeah five
thousand
five thousand that's a part of the
twenty two thousand dollars of debt
it is yeah and then the rest is student
loans okay okay cool i'm a um
yeah i'm gonna pay off pay off your car
today
i need you to hang up for me go pay off
your car today okay
today yes sir yeah yeah i mean as a
matter of fact uh follow me on instagram
send me a screenshot um of you paying
off your car
five thousand dollars i'm gonna give you
uh two hours to do that i expect by the
time i get off for the ramsey show
uh that you've paid off your car um you
got it man
um i want proof of that okay and then
from there
um i want you to pay off the rest of
this stuff and then this is what i want
you to do
um have you taken uh because you're
young zane have you taken uh
financial peace university through our
ramsay plus uh
no i haven't no you haven't okay would
you like to
yes sir if if i step down the limb and
asked kelly to give it to you for free
uh will you do it yes sir absolutely let
me ask you this question
why would you do it well
you know big uh a big motivation for me
growing up
so my dad was a taxi driver supporting a
family of five
um and so kind of watching him struggle
uh growing up has been a big motivation
for me and kind of put a fire
you know under me um and so you know
kind of
to honor his name and and you know
change my family tree is kind of
is is the reason for sure okay all right
i like your why
i like your why here's the thing zane i
want you to stay on the line
kelly's gonna get you a copy it's gonna
be one free year all myself
to put you through ramsay plus for free
you're going to get the every dollar
budgeting tool for free as well you're
going to get on clear budget man
and you are going to live below your
means
you are going to hang up for me and
within the next two hours you're going
to pay off your car
and then you're going to get on
instagram and you're going to screenshot
it and
tag me in it at anthony o'neil
look for that blue check mark that's
right
and i'm going to reshare it and we're
going to show the whole world
that this young 23 year old just paid
off his car and within the next 30 days
he's going to sell his jury and be 100
debt free
and then you're going to give me another
instagram when you pay it off and i'm
going to bring you into my show
and we're going to talk about your
journey and then i'm going to walk you
through
how do you become successful how do you
build true wealth
if we can start at the getting these
young people at 20
23 years old thinking about
the future thinking about legacy
thinking about
generational wealth thinking about
building true wealth man america will be
in a much better place
so saying stay on the line kelly's going
to take care of you
she's going to give you a free year
subscription of ramsay plus you're going
to hang up from her
you can go pay off your car you're going
to screenshot that and share it to me on
instagram
stories then within the next 30 days
you're going to pay off your debt
you will be a millionaire within the
next 20 years and you probably won't be
single too much longer because ladies
love
a debt-free man this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health costume ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
[Music]
verses
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show america
my name is anthony o'neill ramsey
personality uh doing the ramsay show by
myself today
now according to the united states
census bureau nearly one in ten
people relocated last year and you guys
that was in 2020
that means this year there's a good
chance you or
someone you know is planning a huge
move now i know it feels like there
are a thousand unknowns you're juggling
when you're relocating but you cannot
lose focus of one of the most
important personal and financial factors
in your move
your housing now i recommend hiring a
quality real estate agent like one of
our endorsed local providers or elps to
help you find the right home
in your city eops are top performing
experts
in their local market and have years and
i mean years of experience helping folks
just like
you and i to make a successful move
okay uh it's just easy to get it's easy
to get instantly connected with an
indoor circle provider agent just go to
ramsolutions.com for sas
agent to talk with ramsey trusted agent
about how they can help with your
relocation
again that's ramsolutions.com for sas
agent
and one of the main reasons why i uh
endorse and promote
um our eops is because i've used them
for both times i i built a home and
recently i moved during i sold my home
during the pandemic
and moved into another home during the
panty make and
um man my elp
indoor soccer provider you guys i
actually made about an extra
thirty thousand dollars on a house and
than what i thought my house was worth
uh he priced it right and he told me to
be patient and within a matter
of two hours we had a offer above asking
and then we went back and they came back
and offered me some more money now
here's the best thing about it with our
elps
he said okay now we've sold your house
we got to get you into another house and
so we went down
to downtown nashville to get us a nice
little um
town home with a nice little rooftop
balcony you know
and the house was a little bit too
expensive you know i was like i don't
want to
slow down my budget now if he can come
down to my budget i'll do it but you
know me
okay um i gotta be within my budget
bottom line i cannot go over by a dollar
he said okay i got you
and y'all within a matter of three days
he calls me back and he says hey
i got i got the house down to your
budget we need to put an offer in and i
said okay cool let's put the offer in
they accepted my offer
uh below the budget so not only did he
make me money
he also saved me a lot of money and i
walked into my new home
uh with equity in it and so on these
eops you guys we're not just saying this
just to be throwing fluff out there no
i'm actually living this out okay
i use my elp i've used them two times um
and when i move again i would use
honestly the same eop
because i just i trust them they are
good they are experts
and so i really want to go to
ramsolutions.com for slash
agent if you are a family member is
moving
let us help you save money and
make money nathan is with us in
omaha good afternoon nathan how can we
help
hey um thanks for picking my call yeah
um so i have an interesting kind of
situation coming up here it's like a
financial crossroads you might say
okay so my parents are looking at
selling their house this year because
the market's nice and hot and they're
probably going to get the most premium
for the money on it
they want to give my wife and i 60 000
off of that sale
we currently have thirty five thousand
dollars in savings
and by the time we'd like to look at
buying next year
we should have between a hundred and ten
hundred twenty thousand dollars in cash
okay we just paid off all of our credit
card debt we're working on
getting the vehicles paid off we're
projected to have those paid off by the
end of the year
which just leaves my student loan
student loan is at 120
000 so we're going to hit a point where
we're going to have 120
000 in cash and 120 000 on student loans
pay off your loans pay off alone
i mean pay off jobs but i want you debt
free you know
and i know nathan is not a popular thing
i know you're like oh my gosh man i
i could be i could be man i can go no no
no listen here man
how old are you and your wife uh i'm 30
the
wife is 26. oh yeah so you're young so
what you think about this how much do
you all make in a household right now
last year we made 156 000 this year
we'll probably make about 175
and we both put in for promotion so next
year i think we're going to be
right at 200. okay cool
and you're in omaha what's what is the
average house goal for us like if you
went to go purchase a home today
um how much would it cost you like what
what's your dream home
we're looking in the range of uh 200 to
300
000 so average i mean 225
250 okay and how long do you think it
would take you to save
up 20 of that
so i'd be about 50 000. so if we were
debt-free today saving that up would
probably
be seven eight months yeah
all right so let's let's let's let's
let's dream here brother i want you to
follow me
you get this money from your mom from
your parents
you're going to have about 120 thousand
dollars right
yeah you already have 30 000 you said 35
000 in your savings account right now
right
right okay immediately i'm going ahead
and just
dumping all of that into paying off your
debt now then when you sell the house
right i'm taking that money putting that
towards the debt
so if i'm hearing you correctly by the
end of by the beginning of next summer
you can be 100 debt free correct
yeah okay then by the end of next year
you can have 50 000
sitting in your savings account yeah
okay cool
so this means within the next two years
you could be into your home and the only
debt that you have
is a mortgage now here's what i'm saying
within the next two years because it's
going to take you one year to pay off
the debt
then i need you to spend at least three
months stacking up at least a
three-month emergency fund
okay then you need to go ahead and save
up that 20
so that way you can uh put down on that
then us
on top of the 20 you probably need to
stack up at least another 10k
for moving expenses and some extra
things to get into your home
so by the time you turn 32 years old and
by the time your wife turns 28
you can be 100 debt free home owner
millennials killing the game
that is beautiful to me i would rather
do that than to rush into a home
and then i'm still bound in debt nah man
i want you to get into the home have
freedom have peace enjoy your wife enjoy
your life
y'all can get out there and just have
the financial peace and you wake up on
the first of the month
and the only thing you have to pay for
is your mortgage
utilities and insurance bills and eat
that's it
that's it that's peace man
and then from there here's the thing
nathan
i want you to get into that thing
15-year fixed rate and when you get
there man i want you to attack this
mortgage
can you imagine being 100 debt free
on path to being a multi-millionaire by
the time you turn 45 years old
yeah that's what i'm looking at that's
what i'd like to do that's it
no no no no don't say that's what you
like to do say that's what you
will be doing think about it your wife
come on now let's be real man can can i
be real with you nathan i only got like
30 seconds can i be real with you
ladies love financial security let's
just be honest
okay they love it you know when you're a
man when you're leading
you know when y'all are leading together
when you're providing
you know financial security emotional
security white ladies love that
so go ahead and pay off the debt and the
man when y'all pay off that house man
take her to wherever she want to go say
baby girl where do you want to go
wherever she says she want to go take
her if it costs you 10 grand you take
her there
okay i'm telling you right now that's if
i'm in your shoes
that's what i'm doing i'm doing that
right
there man i'm excited for you man
we good nathan yeah that sounds good
all right man it's a big pill to swallow
you know but i guess you just gotta rip
that band-aid off and get it done hey
man listen here
successful people do what unsuccessful
people are not willing to do
nothing extraordinary happens with
inside people's comfort zone
it's going to be uncomfortable but
that's what you're here for
to be uncomfortable so you can be
successful don't allow your comfort zone
to become your kill zone
don't allow what's comfortable to you to
kill your dreams and your goals and your
vision nah
step outside of your comfort zone be
uncomfortable for the next two years
in the next 15 years you're gonna be
amazing you're gonna love it
you're gonna love it well i'm loving
this boy i'm loving this
james i'm gonna tell dave he can take
off all he wants i'll tell the other
personalities too
hey this is the ramsay show we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality and
i am so excited because during this
segment
we have mitchell and alexa on the debt
free
scream stage how y'all doing great how
are you
man so where y'all from ann arbor
michigan ann arbor michigan
yes okay so let's go ahead and get
straight to it
um how much did you pay off i paid off
just over
68 000 and i want to say that it was my
debt-free journey but since we got
married three days ago it became our
legacy what three days ago three days
ago like three days ago from today from
today
i love it all right so how long did it
take you
with her praying with you it took me 20
months
20 months all right cool beans and how
much were you making during those 20
months
i started netting 30 and finished with
45.
what 30 to 45 and you paid off
68 000 in about a year
and eight months man so uh what do you
do for a living
i own a lawn and landscape company oh
man this is amazing the last young kid
was just talking about he wouldn't do
a launch oh this is amazing landscaping
man i wish you live closer i'll hire you
today
so all right so what type of debt was it
that was everything it was
tires phone lawnmower loan
from my parents student loans two
vehicles
everything you had with you were single
you had two cars i had two
trucks yeah two trucks one for the
business and one for the personal yeah
okay okay okay and tires yep
that was probably the first dead i ever
got was getting new tires
oh man so 20 years ago what got you on
this journey what what say you know what
hey
i need to get my life together um so it
started a little bit
before 20 months ago alexa sent me a
quote
live like no one else so later you can
live like no one else and i was like
cool sounds great and then
one of my clients that i mowed for he
actually like he asked me what do you
listen to while
mowing lawns and i told him just country
music whatever and
but i do get sick of music very quickly
because i listened to it all day every
day and he said you should try podcasts
so i was like all right i went on
spotify looked up business podcasts and
uh dave ramsey was the first one to pop
up so i started listening to him and i
was like
dang i could do this i need to provide a
what kind of life do i want to provide
for my future wife because we were
dating at the time starting to get
serious and yeah like
do i want to go into marriage with a ton
of debt or
be debt-free so when did y'all start
dating alexa started dating in 2017. so
it's been a while yeah so what made you
give him the you know the dave ramsey
book and you know stuff like that what
what
were you trying to send him a little
message or were you just like this is
pretty cool or really hey you need to
get this fixed if we gonna get married
well so i had taken um in my high school
they offered the um
the class for financial peace and so i
took that as a senior in high school and
uh
then i actually had paid off some of my
student loan debt as well
all my student loan debt um the first
year i was out of college um and so
that was which also that was at the
point that he was starting to uh to
get into it too and i had a chunk of
cash sitting in my bank account and i
had
student loans that i could pay a large
chunk of so
i did that but then really just uh you
know just when we started thinking about
the future and what our legacy was going
to look like
like doing that together and just having
that vision for the future really
so what was your why like why did you be
like hey i i
i want to get out of debt my wife is 100
standing right next to me are you
serious yeah i mean do i want to
do we want to go in struggling with
money or do we want to go into marriage
completely free and i think that's why
she said yes as quick
yeah it's been awesome like since
or leading up to marriage and getting
married we paid for our
all of our furnishing in cash paid for
the wedding in cash paid for a truck in
cash
like we've it's been awesome we're free
to do whatever we want because we're
debt free and have
good incomes this is this is lovely i
love it all right so let's rewind
um what did you do to get out of debt
because
you were you started off making 30 000.
now let's be honest
that's not a lot of money and everyone
who says well
30 000 i can't i can't pay off no debt
but then you
you did it so give us that journey a
little bit how did you do it
so um we stopped going on as fancy dates
no no that sucked for her a little bit
but she knew why
um i that dream truck that i had the
sweet lifted
hemi all the good stuff i sold that i'm
so sorry
it's all right and then towards the end
of the journey
i also moved back in with my parents
lived rent free i am so sorry
yeah i was living alone for quite a few
years and it was a little tough moving
back in home but
it was worth it it was definitely worth
it man i hear you
now uh what would you say was the
hardest thing i'm asking you this um
alexa
watching your fiance at the time your
now husband go through this journey
what was one of the hardest things you
think he had to endure and encounter
during that time
i would say like definitely just i i
haven't experienced living out
of my parents home until we got married
here but i think that moving
back home was a huge sacrifice and that
was also i'm actually from
jackson michigan so about 30 40 minutes
from ann arbor so and he was going back
to ann arbor with his parents so we were
for both of us it was difficult being 40
minutes apart after being
so so close together for a few years um
but yeah i think that really just
i think that the lord really just helped
us during that time and our i think our
relationship
both through the debt-free journey and
then also just just that distance just
helped us grow
even closer and stronger before heading
into marriage so no
i love it i love it uh so what would you
say is the key
to getting out of debt um definitely
stick to the budget
that helped me a lot and then have your
why
yeah like i couldn't have done it
without knowing that i was doing it for
alexa and our future family yeah i i
really do love that
so you went up by fifteen thousand
dollars what'd you do to go up
just acquired more clients the business
has just been booming and then this year
it's gonna be
even greater it's been insane how much
the pandemic has helped and it's
just gone up from the start and it's
looking like it's just gonna
keep going up yeah yeah i'm looking for
a guy like you to come out to my house
man i wish you lived in asheville hey
it's only a
eight-hour drive i can come do it for
you hey man listen we'll talk after
we'll talk on a break so
um who were your biggest cheerleaders on
the way definitely alexa
pushing me through it um i have another
friend named tom
that he's doing his debt-free journey
right now too and we kind of just talked
and
every every so often just check to see
where we were at
um and he definitely was cheering me on
too and my parents were
supportive i mean they let me move back
home so i couldn't have
i mean it was towards the end but still
that push of
not having to pay rent made it that much
quicker and out if i didn't move home i
don't think i could have
done it before the wedding yeah yeah
yeah you moved back in
your home made some extra money stopped
going out on fancy dates
um had to tell people no so you can
eventually tell her yes
oh yeah this is our honeymoon we've
haven't held back
too much because we got the money to got
the money to do it got the money
um did people think you were crazy
i got a couple naysayers and a couple
like i mean not to make him feel bad but
my brother made fun of me a lot
well your brother's gonna be loving you
now you're you're debt free and he's
gonna try and follow your footsteps
and i absolutely love it so how does it
feel to be 100
debt free newly married
walking into the future with no bondage
i mean it feels amazing like he said i
think really just the
one the lord's faithfulness throughout
this time but then also just um
like he'd mentioned you know being able
to pay for the wedding and cash
furnishing with all new furniture our
home
our first home in cash and uh you know
him buying a truck recently while us
buying a truck
and cash i think has just been really a
testament to the lord's faithfulness um
really and just
you know being good stewards of what
he's given us so i love it
no i really do love it well you guys i'm
just excited to hear your story
and excited to hear your journey so we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
and
the total money makeover since you all
have both already read it we want you to
pass it forward to someone else
maybe to your friend or maybe to your
brother does your brother have any debt
yeah he he's got that he needs the book
we'll give him the book all right so we
have mitchell and alexa from ann arbor
paid off 68 000 in 20 months making 30
to 45
000 a year count it down for us at debt
free stream
three two one we're debt-free
let's go man this
this man this today has been an amazing
day
you know uh seeing two people do a debt
free screen
this is what it's all about america keep
a lot cause when we come back we have
some more
good information for you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
filling in for the other personalities
and our lead personality dave ramsey in
their absence today
it's been a great day it's been a great
hour um i would encourage you all uh
if you are a young person and i'll say
well i think everyone's young but if
you're in the 20s and the 30s
i want to encourage you to go over to my
youtube channel and watch my show the
table with anthony o'neil
this week i am talking about the 10
things to not do with your paycheck
um and the reason why i i i did this
video
um is because i remember getting my
paycheck when i'm 20 when i was 25 years
old
and i would get my paycheck on a friday
and
by the time it turned around to like
next the following wednesday i was broke
i didn't know where my money went and i
did all kinds of things with my paycheck
i didn't
invest it i didn't budget it and so i
really spent
about 45 minutes at the table i pulled
up the white board
and i literally write down do not do
this with your paycheck
do this with your paycheck this is what
you need to do this is how you invest it
this is how you start paying off your
debt
here's the four things you need to be
spending your money on first
and i really want to encourage you to go
over to
my youtube show because i'm trying to be
very very detailed and making sure that
i'm creating
videos and show topics that that are
really helping young people
really identify how to really become
successful
and there's four things that i'm really
focusing on within my brand within my
show
and the number one thing here is
everything starts with a spiritual
uh foundation okay and then when you
have a good strong spiritual foundation
we're gonna talk about your network okay
who who's speaking into your life
who's life are you speaking into what
kind of friends are you surrounding
yourself with
who are you dating are you dating the
right person
no i'm not a relationship expert but i
do understand that your network
impacts your net worth see where i'm
going so that's the next thing that i
talk about is your net worth how do you
build
a positive net worth you do this by
getting out of debt you do this by
following our baby steps you do this by
having a plan for your money
that is congruent and working hand in
hand with your life with your vision for
where you're going
but you really can't know where you're
going if you're not really putting
something positive into your mind
and that's the last thing that i talk
about is our mindset
i'm teaching people to mind their
business
not really to mind their business as far
as instead of other people's business
which we should be doing
but i'm teaching them that their mind is
a
business and if we can be hyper
intentional
hyper focus around our spiritual walk
around our network around our net worth
and around our mindset
we will be successful and so in this
week's video i
really lay down the 10 things you do not
need to do
with your money when you get paid and
these things are crucial and i made
all of these mistakes and so if you are
somebody who's 20 years old 30 years old
or if you know someone in that age
bracket please go over to my youtube
channel watch the video
share the video and i promise you you
will learn something on this
again that's the youtube dot com forward
slash anthony o'deal
it's called the table with anthony
o'neil we have almost 300
000 uh subscribers over there um and i'm
just so happy
that you all are trusting me uh with
giving you the information
so aaron is with us in pensacola florida
good afternoon aaron how can i help
hey good afternoon anthony well i have a
problem with
my wife and buying a new vehicle our
family recently expanded
in the last three years we've had three
children and we
purchased a new car uh my suv
two years ago when we only had one child
we're running into the dilemma that
uh we might need to uh get a minivan
that sort of thing
um currently we can't fit everybody into
the suv
including my mother-in-law and the dog
and i'll go somewhere
i own two cars right now uh both free
and clear
i paid off the uh the uh the new car
and i have a a legacy vehicle passed
down from my grandmother
uh that's in uh pretty good shape but it
is 20 years old
my concern is is if i sell this
recently purchased car from the last two
years
um i've gotten some price quotes and
everything
i'll probably lose about seven thousand
dollars uh from what i paid for it
i want to purchase say a pre-owned
minivan
for around twenty seven thousand dollars
and uh
the gap that i would have in selling um
my recent car would be about seven 000.
now
my thoughts are that my wife thinks we
should
i should sell my older legacy vehicle uh
i believe i should keep it
and we should you know sell our our
newer car because it's paid off we have
cash
and um to go ahead and and buy the new
one
so um i really don't know what's
probably the best decision
um you know money wise uh we have
about 17 000 in savings um you know if
we would have to come out for the
the new vehicle um we'd want to pay for
cash
but we're really just not sure should i
keep the newer vehicle because
i mean it's only two years old it's
still under warranty
it's reliable or should i just try to uh
sell it and keep my legacy asset and uh
get my wife a new car um okay cool
let's start with the basic financials um
what are you what are you making a year
right now household income
uh i make around 50 000 a year
and that's going to increase to about 55
000
um starting in a month from now
i'm going to be on a new pay scale um
i i work for the government go uh
love it all right so right now you're
making 50 000 okay
which could go up to about 55 000 is
your wife working at all
no she's a full-time stay-at-home mom
and um
you know with the three kids love it you
have any debt right now aaron
uh we have zero debt uh we own our other
than a mortgage
uh we took out a year ago and uh we've
been
we've been paying on that um like
double payments when we can um and then
also
i i contribute to a tsp
uh for my savings i put about 15 percent
of my
income into that um so we've got a
pretty pretty good cushion
real quick aaron we're about to go uh to
a break
um if you sold your your old car legacy
how much could you sell it for
i could i right now i could sell for 22
000.
for 22 000. uh no uh
the the old car i'd probably get uh
maybe in this market
fifteen hundred to two thousand dollars
uh it's low mileage and
in excellent mechanical condition okay
cool
um here's what i do if i'm in your shoes
um
you can't go wrong with either or okay
um how much is the other car worth your
new car
uh right now if i were to sell it i'd
get twenty two thousand for it twenty
two thousand articles
so here's here's the thing that we teach
we wanna make sure that your
cars values do not add up more than
fifty percent of your income
well you're only making fifty thousand
dollars so this means that
uh the the new card you have is is is
worth more than
half your income uh but since you
already have it paid off
i like the fact of you having a reliable
car
i do not believe we need to spend twenty
six twenty seven thousand dollars to get
a brand new car
be the brand new s uh uh van for your
wife
i think you can go out there and find
you a good reliable car for about in
between ten and twelve thousand dollars
so if i'm you i'm selling the old school
legacy card because it's gonna require
you to put some money into it
in future months to keep it running and
going okay so i would take that money
put that on top of the ten thousand
dollars
and then go buy a quality used van
now you have two quality paid for cars
and you're not buying any more cars no
time soon
okay because your income just doesn't
justify it
all right and so what i would do that's
what i would do now if you want to sell
the new car
and keep the used car then you need to
up your savings account go buy it
go buy a van but you got to up your
savings account because you're going to
run into issues with that older car
so with it already being paid for i like
keeping the quality up underneath
warranty card
get you a good quality van and then
really focus on getting your
income up and focusing on um building
your wealth long term so
those are my two cents on that um i
definitely um
appreciative of you calling in um it's
been amazing
you know it's been amazing america
talking to you all throughout this hour
james chad our producer is back in the
building he decided to take off half of
the show
but i'm happy to have him back and kelly
daniel is still with us
hey that's the wrap for this hour we'll
see you all again soon
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony o'neil
ramsey personality and also the host of
the youtube and podcast show the table
with
anthony o'neil and i am hosting solo
today
dave ramsey and other amazing
personalities are out here
impacting the world and they asked me to
step in and i told him sure alone gets
james child and
kelly daniel and ben is in the building
not bob but
ben triple eight eight two five five two
two
five is the number anytime that i'm
gonna show you guys know whether i'm
with dave or any of the other
personalities or by myself i like to
keep it real relevant and relatable
for all people and i have a special
heart you know for younger people who
are in her 20s and 30s and i love all
people
you know but as the only single
personality i really love talking to
single
young thriving uh people who want to be
successful
and so if you want to call in today's
show and talk about your money
talk about a single life what should you
do how should you date how should you
even go about adding dating to your
budget that's right
because i'm on a mission to get our
young people dating on a budget
stop dating above their means a date
within their means so if you're young if
you're single
or if you're older and you're single you
just want to get some advice give me a
call i love talking
um i believe that the value of uh
my advice is exactly what you paid for
it
nothing i'm just playing hey bailey is
in oklahoma
good afternoon bailey how can we help
hi anthony thank you for taking my call
i have a
health buying question i hope you could
help me with um
my husband and i uh just found out we
were expecting our third child
wow um congrats and thank you
um and so we're trying to our house is
very small we're
uh wanting to get it on the market um
and
sell it but we don't know if we should
um
rent with the market being related or if
we should purchase
um okay all right all right so you may
have said this but i might i might have
slipped up and missed it are you
currently
um uh owning right now are you renting
um we own the home um when we sell it
we expect we're kind of waiting on um
everything like um
we're gonna get a smart buster pro and
um we're expecting
maybe to get 100 110 is what we're
thinking
they'll get for it which would be best
with maybe a 70 to 80
000 down payment on our next house
so you're expecting about a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in equity
correct um
well the house is about twenty thousand
dollars from being
completely paid off okay okay and how
much are you going to sell it for
well that's that's what we're hoping to
get 100 or 110.
it's not in the market quite yet okay
okay okay okay so you have about 70 to
80k to put down
okay sounds good um and then uh
tell me this do you have any other debt
right now
yeah we are debt-free i love it you are
100
debt free okay and what are you all
making um a year right now
household 100 120 000
okay 120 thousand dollars in household
income
and if you were to go buy a house today
how much do you think you would have to
pay
um like what will be what are we
speaking budget for a house
yes ma'am okay um very
top 250 um we're probably
wanting to keep it down to the 220 230.
yeah 220 2 30 in oklahoma city right now
in this
i mean i think that that might be a
little tough i'm not saying it's
impossible
uh but i do believe it's a little tough
um
like me being cheap we could probably do
240
250 range but yeah well would your
household income at 120
um 25 of your net pay yeah you could
probably afford right around there
up to about 250 uh in a very comfortable
comfortable situation um let me ask you
this
what's wrong with renting until this
housing situation gets a little bit
better because here's the thing i don't
mind you selling your house and getting
every dollar for it and then some
but i do have a problem with you
overpaying to get another
oh yeah yes we don't have a problem with
renting we've just we've been
working and it's hard to find
our houses are kind of hard to find
right now how old are your kids
um baking four and two
so you have four two and a newborn on
the way
yes okay so if you
have two dogs and two dogs okay so
what do you think how many bedrooms do
you think you have to have
for the let's say if you're going to
sacrifice for the next two years
save up some more money how many
bedrooms could you get by with
three okay you need three minimum okay
and can you find a three-bedroom
apartment
well i have a very very large dog and we
have a lot of equipment
and stuff and so be hard to store that
an apartment
yeah i understand i have a very large
dog too she's very large
and so i totally understand about that
but i could still if i had to i could
still live in an apartment but i
understand you have two kids one on the
way
um here's my thing i i'm gonna suggest
that you rent
uh because i don't i don't see you
paying
right now um i don't see you getting a
good deal
i will not move into the house if i'm
paying a hundred percent of what the
house is worth i
i'm going to get a good deal even when i
built my house they gave me a good deal
on building the house when i just bought
my new house within the last few months
oh they came down quite a bit on the
price uh because i want a good deal
i'm not going to give you 100 and i'm
definitely not giving you a hundred
and one plus percent and so what i'm
saying look at your options
give yourself a timeline a deadline
i'll say okay if we can take this the
equity that we're gonna get from the
house
if we can find a house that's within our
budget that's for a great deal
let's move forward not saying that it's
impossible i'm just saying it's going to
be hard
because as soon as the houses are going
on the market right now they're selling
like cut cakes
and for right now a lot of them selling
for more than what they're actually
worth
um and then let's say for example if you
don't find something by then then just
go rent something
and i think i'm estimating about 12 to
18 months we should see
the housing market kind of shift a
little bit and then from there
you and your husband be in a better
situation because you all actually now
have
more money in your savings account but i
want what i want to recommend to you
under bailey is to um spend these next
if you go into an apartment i want you
to spend these next 12 to 18 months
trying to live i mean extremely way
below your means
so this way you can go out there and get
the house that you
really want and get the house that you
can raise your kids
um up in while as was going through
middle school and in high school
you know and so i'm i'm thinking maybe
bare minimum a three bedroom
four bedroom house you know 16 to 200
square feet
nice backyard for your kids and for your
dog and i think if you can just
sacrifice for the next 12 to 18 months
you're not racking up any debt you're
dropping money into your savings account
you're eating at home
you're out here shopping and looking
around i think you'll be happy over the
next 18 months
when you get that house that you dream
for but don't rush into it just get into
a home and overpay
but spend some time think about it pray
on it and you never know what god
what god would do ah man triple eight
eight two
five five two two five it's your boy
anthony o'neil the host
of the table with anthony o'neil and i'm
on the rams show today taking your phone
calls give me a call i would love to
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality and
and then and in the last segment we were
talking about the housing market and how
hot it is because it is the housing
market is hot and your house could be
worth a lot more today as well than what
it was when you first bought it
so that means your old insurance policy
might not give you enough
coverage anymore and what's the point of
paying for insurance that won't swing
the cost
to repair or rebuild your home if your
home's value
has gone up or it's been over a year
since you checked your homeowner's
policy
talk to one of our endorsed local
providers these independent agents will
compare
multiple quotes to find the best
coverage for your home
and here's the key word your budget
text home h-o-m-e to three three seven
eight nine again that's home to three
three seven
eight nine and talk with a trusted
insurance pro
about finding the right coverage for you
and
your family uh chantelle is with us in
houston texas good afternoon chantel how
can we help
hey good afternoon um thank you for
having me i'm a huge fan of yours and
the dave's show
um so i'm gonna try to keep it concise
for you okay
i'm 33 year old woman i live in houston
i
am i'm single and i make i'm a full-time
teacher
i make uh 56 for okay um
i do uber sometime on the side and i
have a health coaching business that
i've um
started that i i'm not currently making
any money in but
i'm i'm working on it um and
i feel like i've been budgeting i've
been doing the things but i'm not saving
anymore and i'm not um and i'm not
paying any extra towards my debt because
i feel like i'm
really just getting by um
and so i'm trying to find ways to
reduce my debt right now because it's
really making me feel like
a little desperate i do want to be
debt-free and i feel like
unless i it's just a lot of stress
around like trying to grow a business
that's not making any money
and trying to find ways to hustle to pay
off this debt without taking away from
that
and so i came up with the idea yesterday
of what if i sold my
vehicle i have a i have about 80 000
in debt okay um 20
900 comes from the vehicle um
6500 comes from consumer debt which were
investments that i made in coaches to
help me grow my business
and the rest of student loans um
the vehicle itself has about it's
worth about fourteen thousand dollars
but being a dumb kid
in my 20s and rolling over into my 30s
i've rolled over
my old debt into a new vehicle and so
i'm negative
in that vehicle and so
what i thought about doing is going to a
dealership
and trading it in for a used
used car um to lower
the actual debt so it's all in with the
negative equity and the
car payment being under 10 000 i feel
like i would be able to get rid of that
sooner than the two years that it would
take to pay it off
um yeah but what you're going to do is
just roll over that negative equity as
well though
into that so i think what we got to do
is just step back
and reassess the entire financial
situation
so you make fifty six thousand four
hundred dollars a year
right yeah yeah uh when you do uber
like if you were to get hyper
intentional uh
how much extra can you make a month
ubering well i just started that back
because i was really relying on my
business growing
um but if i wanted to
really go full time into doing that
especially being offered a summer i
could add about another thousand
or so um safely
yeah a month probably even more i mean
yeah i was gonna say you can do a little
bit more than that
well yeah but you know in my mind i'm
also thinking it costs for gas it costs
for all that stuff so even though you
make money you also lose it by having to
replace the gas and stuff like that but
yes i could probably do about 2 000
extra a month okay 2 000 extra a month
right there all right
during the summer for sure yeah and then
you got your school teacher so i i
definitely appreciate your service and
helping our young people thank you
yeah for sure um now okay so we got two
thousand dollars extra month that we can
get right there right
um so that'll bring you up to right
around like 70.
and then you have seven thousand dollars
in debt twenty thousand dollars nine
hundred dollars in a car what kind of
car is it
it's a 2018 jeep cherokee um
you got a lot of miles on it it's only
35 000 miles on it
um yeah but you wrote in a lot of
negative equity
about six grand and so that i'm actually
in the carmax bathroom because i was
gonna go get it
appraised to see if i could go trade it
in for something lower because i feel
like if i had
a lower like overall you got car max
right now
yeah oh no no no no
when we get off the phone listen listen
here santel you're gonna walk
straight out walk right past the
salesman okay
i will tell you do that right now but
you know i need i need to hear you
clearly so i'm going to say right there
in the bathroom
this is dope i like this i'm talking to
her in the bathroom this one i'm talking
about
she's serious about this lifestyle i
gotta talk to anthony i need to get out
of debt that's right girl you stay right
there in the bathroom
i do i need to get out of debt all right
so let's do this all right how much
money do you have in your savings
account right now
um 1500. okay 1500 okay you're going to
keep that
and you're going to keep that in your
savings account right now all right
um so you have you have a couple of
options you have some options here um
right now what you got to figure out is
that car that car is
a huge problem so i would not suggest
trading it in and then stacking on more
debt
what i would advise you to do is sell
the car
okay and then whatever you can sell the
car for
then go take out a personal loan for the
difference
now listen what i'm saying here is if
you can sell the car
for 16 000 then what i'm saying is go
get a loan for 4 500 bucks
to to do the difference or whatever that
math is so you go down from 20
900 in debt to only 5 000
debt now the problem is going to be that
you need to pay
cash for a used car
this means that you're not going to be
able to drive a car max car
because you're going to drive past
carmax when you get off the phone with
me okay
yes right so so that's what i would
recommend is go back to kelly blue book
see what you can privately sell the car
for and then whatever they say
private sale is you sell it for that
then i am
okay with you going to get a personal
loan to replace the difference
okay and then that goes inside of your
debt snowball but then the next thing
is you're going to use your emergency
fund to go ahead and buy you
a cash car and i'm talking about here
a chantel you need to be spending right
around two to three grand
to get you a cash car okay so this means
that you may need to keep your car
um so you can get a little bit more
money up to get a little bit more money
up to go buy a cash card
but that's the first process do not
trade this in because a car salesman is
going to talk you into something that's
not going to be a wise move for you all
right
okay then from there you're just going
to take the debt snowball method you're
going to line up all your debt from
smallest to largest
make all your minimum payments you're
going to be out there ubering
chantal like you're going to be out
there ubering from sun up to sun down
you are 33 years old you're single you
have any kids
no yeah so right now you have no kids
right now you have no kids
you have no friends you have no
boyfriend you don't have
nothing you don't have time for nothing
right now
the next two years is about you getting
out of debt if a man come into your life
chantal
and and he talking about i want to do
this no if he ain't helping you get
towards your goals
you don't have time for all right bottom
line
so this is what i want you to do i want
you to stay on the line i'm gonna have
kelly give you access to
ramsey plus okay the very first thing i
want you to want to go sign up for that
and take
our classes okay i want you to sit down
with us get connected with our community
then the next thing you're gonna do is
you're gonna go home and figure out how
can you sell this car
and what kind of car can you get for
right around two grand twenty five
hundred dollars
then after that you're gonna go back
onto youtube
okay and you're gonna subscribe to my
channel and i'm gonna walk you through
this journey
okay now get out of carmax get out of
the bathroom
go straight to your car get in your car
go home
okay go home connect with us we're going
to walk you through this process
i'm giving you this ramsey plus for free
on me
because i want to help you turn your
life around america this is what it's
about man this is what it's about
call me in the bathroom that's what i'm
talking about that's when i know you
intentional
about getting out of debt this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
and uh arturo is with us in salt lake
city
good afternoon arturo how can i help
hey anthony how you doing man i'm doing
all right man it's been a great
great great day man how can help
all right um so me and my wife um are
both on our way
out of the military we're currently on
terminal leave
so we have about a month left of pay
and i'm looking to do a career change
right now
but just looking for some advice and
guidance as to
if now is the right time um so we
recently just moved to
utah which is a new state for both of us
she has some family out here
so far i love it um and i want to be a
real estate agent
i just don't know if now is the right
time whether i should
jump into the game now or you know go
back to school
use my gi bill focus on being a
full-time student
okay so let's look at all of our options
here uh bro
if you went back to school and you were
a full-time student
how would you and your wife survive and
before you answer that question thank
you
so much uh for serving your country we
value and appreciate people
people like you and your wife so again
thank you thank you so much
um for your time and service um but if
you went back to school full time
i like the education because i it's free
education
but how would you pay your bills right
so um if we both go back to school
full-time uh
using uh our gi bill they will pay us a
monthly housing allowance which for both
of us it would be
uh or actually each of us it would be
fifteen hundred dollars a month
and uh i brought my monthly expenses
down
to be just above that right now so
obviously
i would still wanna work part-time so
it'd be going to school full-time
getting that housing allowance
and working part-time jobs so fifteen
hundred dollars for two is three
thousand dollars and you're saying that
you're right around what
sixteen seventeen hundred bucks for your
housing uh
for your living expenses right now uh
that's for each of us
right so so we're right we're right at
that mark where
we could live off of you know uh
off of our housing allowance but have
nothing for
any extra or it'd be very strict yeah
yeah
okay and if you went to school what
would you go out of school for
um i am looking for something in
business uh right now i'm thinking
finance
okay and what would you use a finance
degree for
uh so if you know i said i wanted to be
a real estate agent
uh i'm kind of using my finance degree
too where if that doesn't work out
i'm looking for something in either an
hr position
uh marketing something like that yeah
because you don't need a degree to be a
real estate agent
right right correct yeah i'm kind of
using the degree as
you know they provide that monthly
housing allowance but it's also like a
backup plan
i got you so you you're going to get you
want to get the degree so you can get
the three thousand dollars
um which which i understand it's free
education and you getting three thousand
dollars so i can understand that
i think for me is how much debt are you
all how much debt do you all have right
now
so we've paid off all that except for
our cars
uh which total for both of us is around
just under 26 000.
okay twenty six thousand dollars in cars
how much money do you have in your
savings
uh yeah to add to that um
instead of continuing with our debt
snowball since we were close to getting
out
um we kind of just started saving and
building our emergency fund
so we have right now right around 25 000
hopefully once the navy finishes paying
us and reimbursing us for moving
expenses all that
we should be at about 30. okay
so there you all right all right
and let's say for an example and i'm
just trying to make sure let's say once
you get off in a month
and you don't go back to school what's
your what's your goal
what are you going to do for income so
if i weren't to go back to school
i would just jump straight into the real
estate field
do that full-time and that's sort of why
i kind of plan to use that emergency
fund because i know
you know the real estate field not
stable income so
i'm gonna have to you know be paying
myself for a little bit
a little bit until that income starts
rolling in uh it's just i feel like that
uh
i still i still have that car debt
over me so i don't know whether i should
you know just jump in full time
uh keep doing what i'm doing or take a
step back go to school
pay off our debt and then build another
emergency fund
you know when i listen to you man i'm
nothing that you've said respectfully uh
has got me really excited
you know um you know the real estate
industry right now it's gonna take you
six months to a year to really start
building
you know a solid stable income sometimes
a bit longer than that it all just it
really all depends
um and so i'm a little nervous about
that then i'm a little nervous about
depending on
me going back to school to provide for
my life
now i do like the part of you getting
education especially a
free education especially to get paid to
get your education
i like that but here's what's not making
me as excited
we don't really have a clear path and
this is something
that um my counterpart ken coleman talks
about is
really getting a clear path and
identifying
exactly what you want to do and i think
before we can really help you i think
you and your wife
should really sit down and be like hey
hey what do we want to do or what do
i want to do when i leave the military
um do i want to be a real estate agent
if that's what you know you
really want to do then what i would say
is get into that industry but man you
need to figure out a job
that will provide income because you got
twenty six thousand dollars in debt
my goal is and what i would love to see
you do is
take this this thirty thousand dollars
pay off all your cars so you have
no responsibilities no debt and then you
just have your
housing your food and your utilities
that you need to pay for which that
shouldn't be expensive at all
and then if you have a job generating
between you and your wife making at
least another three thousand thirty five
hundred dollars a month
together combined in a household
while you're in real estate because if
that's what you want to do i want you to
go after what you want to do
there is money in the game but it's
going to take a while for you to build
that money but if you're saying hey i
really do want to go back to school
and i really want to pursue this okay
cool let's talk about that option as
well
but what i hear from you is like well i
want to do this but if this doesn't work
i can do this
then if that doesn't work then i'm at
least to have school paying for this now
i need to hear passion in your voice
i need to hear this is what i want to do
this is what i am going to do
and i'm going to do everything that i
have to do and so
i really think uh that you need to get
connected with ken coleman
okay he is our expert in this field
and so what i want to do is encourage
you to call into the show tomorrow ken
coleman show
um go to the kingcomashow.com and you'll
be able to see exactly what time his
his show airs and call in and tell him
hey your friend anthony told me to give
you a call
this is where i'm at can you help me
walk through a clear path to identify
what is the best route for me to do with
me getting out of the service
and then when you do that i mean i'm
telling you right now um it will be
absolutely um amazing um and so
artero i'm rooting for you bro i really
am but i really can't help someone who
really
doesn't know what they really really
want to do
so go to kingcoleman.com and
kingcombingshow.com and look up at his
hours for when his show is going to be
running he does it live on youtube and
he does it live on series xm
tell him that anthony o'neil tell his
screen phone or that anthony o'neil
told you to call they'll push you
through
and i want you to run through the same
scenario with ken and ken is going to
walk you through a clear
journey in this journey is the best
journey out there
period you know um um i
i like the education part but it's not
exciting me i like you selling
houses but it's not exciting because i
don't hear the excitement inside of you
um but give ken a call
give ken a call this is why i love what
i do because i'm not an expert in
everything
we can talk about money all day long but
ken coleman is the
expert when it comes to getting that
career right when it comes to building
that shovel
now once you get that career right and
you got some money coming in and then
come back and holler at me and dave
we'll walk you through this path we'll
get you some money we'll show you how to
flip that thing and pay off the debt
uh but america if you're struggling
right now
if you're not happy in your career space
check out my boy ken coleman
the author of the proximity principle
the number one radio show out there when
it comes to getting your careers and
building your shovel
then come holla at me at the table let
me help you get your money right
and maybe dave too
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
and our scripture and quote comes from
ephesians chapter 4 verses 32
and it says be kind and compassionate to
one another forgiving each other
just as in christ god forgave you
john maxwell says you build trust with
others
each time you choose integrity over
image
truth over convenience or honor over
personal gain
taylor is with us in dallas texas good
afternoon taylor how can we help
hi anthony how are you i'm doing great
now that you've called it
so uh how can i all help
so i'm calling because my question is
mainly centered around the amount of
our debt that my husband and i and i
have between the two of us
okay you say car debt yeah well
yeah so we have recently decided to be
smart and get out of debt
we have a total of 141 thousand dollars
in debt
and of this a hundred thousand and
a hundred thousand of this is car debt
no it's not
yes no no no no this this
you're not you're not being for real
right now are you
no i i am being serious um i am
definitely being serious
what are you all driving well we both
have luxury vehicles
that we both love and so
the thing we have been going back and
forth on if we should sell the cars and
get something
you know cheaper or just pay it down we
think we could be debt-free by
the end of 2022
um maybe maybe a little bit sooner
so we're you know trying to decide if we
could pay this off and
we give ourselves a goal of you know
anywhere between a year and a year and a
half
if it's worth it to keep them because we
both love our cars but we also don't
like the idea that we paid
over a hundred thousand dollars for two
vehicles for two vehicles
all right uh before i flip out what's
y'all's household
income so our base
inc between the two of us our base
salary is 275
but on an average year it's usually
around 320 but can go
as high as 360. okay so
all right all right all right i was i
was about to flip off taylor
i i was about to go off a hundred
thousand dollars in cars
i was about to have a heart attack over
here but okay you all are making 300
000 plus all right so uh the scary part
for me is
you know um how much do you all have in
savings right now i'm curious
we have about 50 to 60 000.
50 to 60 000 so you all have enough
money in your savings account right now
to pay off one car and it'll be down
okay so what's the problem like what
y'all disagree with getting out of debt
all right i mean what's the problem well
so
i think that we should sell them and get
something a little bit more
reasonable i think we suffered from
lifestyle inflation
as our salaries have increased
um i do love my car he loves his car he
doesn't want to sell him he just kind of
wants to pay them off
over time we have two kids
and they're both in daycare so that you
know kids are just expensive
okay and so trying to convince him that
we could be debt-free a lot sooner
because we work with them and get them
get you know
something around 20 to 25
that we could just kind of pay cash for
okay
so here's the thing let's let's let's
let's let's break down the basics
because i think a lot of people in the
ramsey world are
like oh my god a hundred thousand
dollars of cars let's be real
okay we teach that your cars should not
add up to be more than 50
of your income your household income so
you all are making 300 000
so you are well below that
okay so let's let's go ahead and just
say you're in a safe
place where i do agree with you
is if you genuinely want to be 100 debt
free
quicker than yes selling the cars would
be a good option
now here's my thing
if i'm in your shoes and i love these
cars and i'm making your
income okay as a husband and wife
and i have sixty thousand dollars in my
savings account
i'm generating a good amount of money
every single month okay
right i'm taking that that i'm taking 59
000 of that i'm paying off
one car today and then me and my wife
are going to be very gazelle intense
over the next
seven months to pay off the rest of our
debt
we're going hard like we're we're not
going out on dates
we're we're not you know doing vacation
here this summer
we're not doing a lot of things we're
going to eat comfortably
we're going to live comfortably but
we're going to be very
focused on paying off all of our debt
okay that's what i would do if i love
the cars
like i got a very nice car too you know
and if i was in your situation
i would just say you know what i'm gonna
focus and pay off this car
if i'm making that kind of money and so
for you
and your husband i think this is where
you two come together
sit down and have a clear conversation
if your husband
wants to um keep his car then hey take
that 59 thousand dollars go pay off the
car
and then you and your husband said all
right cool let's get on a clear budget
let's get start living below our means
and let's pay
off all of our debt and then get our
emergency fund back up
now that's one route now if you want to
get out of that quicker and be debt-free
within the next six months
yeah sell both of the cars buy buy a
couple of cash cards
pay off you know the rest of your debt
and boom great uh but i think
you all are in a financial place to
where you two can choose
because if dave was here this is what
dave was saying number one
your cars are less than 50 percent
number two you can be
debt free within the next two years so
the option is on you
okay um i genuinely believe
so if you take if you take 59 you guys
got 141. that's 61.20
something's gonna have about eighty
thousand dollars more you all are making
three twenty three fifty you saying on
the high end 360.
so i mean within the next nine to 12
months
you and your husband can be 100
debt-free how old are you two
um so i'm 28 and he is 30. oh
y'all y'all millennials making this kind
of money
oh my gosh i see why y'all got this card
i mean listen
y'all need to come over here and rock
with me on my show so when you hang up
for me
you need to go hit subscribe on my
youtube channel uh because i'm i'm gonna
help you all out some more okay you need
hit subscribe
uh to the table with anthony o'neil get
you and your husband and i want y'all to
go
and actually watch this week's show
because i sit here and tell you all what
not to do with your paycheck all right
so that's number one
uh number two have you two uh taking uh
financial peace university inside of
ramsay plus
no no we haven't okay cool this is my
third one today i love giving away dave
ramsey stuff you know
you know i love it so i want you to stay
on the line kelly is going to give you a
um
a free trial to ramsey plus i want you
and your husband to take it
um and honestly you two can choose
uh taylor what you two want to do you
two are in a
good financial place to where you can be
debt free within the next nine to 12
months
and i say if you two love the car and
you know you can keep this car for a
very long time
i may side with your husband because i
do like nice things i'm not gonna front
and and if i can pay off these nice
things within a matter of two years and
be debt-free completely
i'm just gonna go that route um so i
think you two sit down and figure out
what do you both want and just have a
good conversation from there
all right well that's good to hear it
just sounds crazy to me to have
cars that are over you know six figures
it just sounds crazy
i mean it it it sounds crazy but you're
in a good and healthy place financially
to do it
um and and that's just from what we
teach you can be debt-free within two
years
and your cars both of your cars are not
worth more
than your household income okay so you
are in you're in a good place
financially
but i totally understand how you feel
and again this goes back to just you and
your husband sitting down having a
conversation
if you all really want to become debt
free and not have a hundred thousand
dollars in cars
uh then y'all can be debt free within
within a matter of the next you know
nine months and if y'all really go hard
yo you could be debt-free within a
matter of the next six months
you could be one of your cars and you
paid off today that's what i would do
i'm i'm calling the bank and paying it
off today today
you still gonna have ten thousand
dollars i'll take the other nine
thousand dollars and put that towards
the savings account not savings account
towards your other debt
and just really start attacking that
stuff so you all can be financially free
well today's been amazing i want to
thank our producer james child that's
filled in for half of the show
i want to thank our associate producer
kelly daniel who's been rocking with me
the entire show
and america i want to thank you for
being the number one
group of people out there in america so
don't forget that the caliber of your
future
will be determined by the decisions we
made today and you all you made the
right decision
by rocking with the ramsey family we'll
see you on the next show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you